hat so ein bisschen so billig charakter
auch nach einem eckball ist richtig
lecker so einstreute teil entstehen
demnächst etwas weg
[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute eine tat
trophy zieren das hört sich schon
richtig gut an und das ist auch richtig
lecker das ist nämlich eine spezialität
aus sand tropez und zwar ist es ein trio
aus also ein richtig luft dünner
hefeteig gefüllt mit einer extrem
leckeren wandeln der creme ich starte
direkt mit dem hefeteig und schreibe
euch alle ganz gern mengenangaben wie
immer hier unten in die video
beschreibung ich nehme zwar eine
küchenmaschine aber natürlich könnt ihr
auch wie immer ein rührgerät benutzen
und gibt mir jetzt trocken hierfür dazu
ich hatte jetzt keine frische da aber
das macht auch nichts mit rockin eve
funktioniert das auch sehr gut und dann
verliere ich das schon miteinander
zucker könnt ihr schon mit dazugeben und
dann kommen oder kommt besser gesagt
noch eine mischung aus also vollei und
eiweiß mit rein weil das eigelb ein
eigelb bewahren und zwar auf befragen
wir gleich zum verstreichen und das
lasse ich dann einfach kneten und gibt
dann anschließend die zimmer waren
butter mit dazu ihr könnt ihr übrigens
jetzt auch schon seit mit dazugeben
geben nochmal den süßen geschmack
[Musik]
ich hatte die eier übrigens ver quält
und dann rein gegeben und jetzt haben
wir schon extrem klebrigen teig da kommt
jetzt noch butter dazu ich habe das
ganze übrigens 67 minuten lang auf
niedrigster stufe einfach geknetet bis
es sich verbunden hat ich habe dann
nichts weiter gemacht außer so ein
bisschen noch die trockenen zutaten
damit reingeschoben und jetzt nehme ich
mir die butter die ist zimmer waren die
habe ich gerade schon vor ich glaube
zwei stunden aus dem kühlschrank
genommen und das kommt jetzt auch
häppchenweise mit dazu und wird dann
auch noch mal richtig schön lange so 3
45 minuten lang ein geknetet
[Musik]
so jetzt ist der teig fertig und ihr
dürft euch nicht wundern der ist extrem
klebrig aber genau so muss er sein denn
der wird jetzt nochmal bzw zweimal aber
jetzt erstmal gehen gelassen ich habe
jetzt hier eine schüssel und gibt da
noch mal ordentlich mehr rein und dann
kommt der teig mit dazu geht nochmal mit
mehl überdeckt und dann zugedeckt eine
stunde an einem warmen ort gehen lassen
bevor es weitergeht
[Musik]
wir bereiten jetzt die füllung vor das
wird eine leckere vanillepudding creme
eine so genannte kombi trocken dafür
stehe ich jetzt hier am herd ich gehe
jetzt erstmal mich in meinem kopf der
härte 690 eingeschaltet da kann direkt
sogar mit dazu und ordentlich vanille
extrakt das ist es der geschmacksträger
im rezept wird ja schließlich eine
vanillecreme und ich finde es ganz
interessant weil entstanden ist die tat
tropez ziehen einfach durch einen
polnischen konditor der bei einem dreht
das war 1950 also vor 70 jahren er hat
bei einem dreh einfach diese tat
offiziellen mitgebracht ein dreh mit
brigitte bardot habe ich das richtig
gemacht die stadt war die gitarre doch
auf jeden fall kennen sie wahrscheinlich
alles mitgebracht alle haben gefeiert
der dreh hat in der nähe von
saint-tropez stattgefunden und sie hat
dann quasi den namen vergeben und
dadurch wurde total bekannt und den
gibt's mittlerweile eigentlich überall
und ich wollte ihn einfach unbedingt mal
selber machen und jetzt werde ich
erstmal die milch erwärmen ich nehme
meine schneebesen achtung bei milch kann
ja auch immer schnell brennen daher
immer schön dabei bleiben parallel mache
ich es aber so dass ich ein gelb mit
speisestärke verriet zwei minuten lang
einfach schlagen und sobald die milch
dann erwärmt wurde die muss nicht
hochkochen wirklich nur erwerben geben
wie sie quasi zur alp mischung
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt die warme milch mischung
einfach eingerührt in die gelb masse das
eiweiß brauchen wir an der stelle nicht
das könnt ihr euch auf bewahren ihr
könnt damit eine buttercreme machen oder
was man auch gut machen kann sind
macarons dazu muss ich euch auch wieder
ein rezept zeigen in mein altes macao
rezept das ist schon fünf jahre alt und
ich muss einfach noch mal neu drehen und
das rezept ist aber genial shots ich
gerne an wenn ihr mögt ich werde jetzt
einfach alles nochmal zurück füllen in
den topf und dem herd noch mal
einschalten
alles muss jetzt unter ständigem rühren
einmal aufgekocht und eingedeckt werden
damit sie noch die ganzen man in langsam
drehen die werde ich jetzt natürlich
auch alle noch in meinem körper
rausholen sobald der pudding dann
eingedeckt ist könnt ihr auch schon
brutal mit dazu geben und zwar genau der
rest an butter den wir hier noch gerade
von brio steig haben wir wittern innen
warm pudding gleich eingerührt und dann
müssen wir ihn vollständig abkühlen
lassen am besten mit frischhaltefolie
bedecken damit sich auch keine haut
bildet
[Musik]
so unser pudding dafür jetzt auskühlen
und wir machen weiter mit unserem teig
ich habe jetzt hier auch noch weiteres
mehr braucht wirklich im nachgang noch
mal viel mehl es gibt da jetzt auch
einiges davon auf einer arbeitsfläche
und dann kommt der teig einmal darauf
wird jetzt noch mal ganz grob also bei
merck schon der ist immer noch sehr
klebrig aber schon ein bisschen fester
geworden
die konsistenz hat sich ein wenig
verändert
und der wird jetzt einfach nur mit den
händen und mit mehr mail ganz grob
nochmal geknetet und wenn ihr dann einen
teig habt ihr etwas fester ist und nicht
mehr ganz so doll an den fingern klebt
kommt er auch wieder zurück in die
schüssel wird gewählt und dann braucht
ja auch noch mal geduld weil dann haben
wir zwei stunden wartezeit aber das
ergebnis kann sich sehen lassen das wird
mir richtig viel luftiger und lockerer
teig
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt noch mehr in den teig
eingearbeitet ganz vorsichtig und das
ist so ein tag also wenn ich jetzt so
anfasse kippte zwar nicht mehr mein
finger aber ich merke und runter dass er
sich so ein bisschen den weg zwischen
die finger sucht also der sagt schon ein
in die finger ich weiß nicht ob ich das
jetzt richtig erklären kann ich darüber
wie man es nach macht dann weiß man
genau was ich meine aber mir ist wichtig
dass die auch nicht zu viel mehl 1
bietet weil er soll ja schön locker und
luftig werden und nicht zu trocken jetzt
wie gesagt noch mal ordentlich mehl in
eine schüssel den teig herein und mehl
noch mal oben drüber und dann zugedeckt
noch mal die zwei stunden aushalten aber
ich warte jetzt auch darauf dass mein
pudding auskühlt ich mach das mal alles
schön parallel dann ist es ein bisschen
entspannter dann zeige ich euch wie es
mit der pudding creme weitergeht und
wieder nutzen wir die zwischenzeit das
ist echt cool man kann wirklich immer
hin und her switchen zwischen boden und
creme beziehungsweise teig und creme und
ich habe jetzt hier meinem ein pudding
der ist komplett ausgekühlt hatte ihn
jetzt auch ein kühlschrank und da kommt
jetzt einmal kalte schlagsahne auch ganz
frisch aus dem kühlschrank in die
schüsse und wir da zusammen mit sahne
fast komplett steif geschlagene mich
jetzt einfach mal handrührgerät das ist
jetzt nicht so eine große menge oder
machen wir mit dem frühling weiter
[Musik]
so die sahen ist es schön steif ich
liebe es hier einmal die folie ab und
jetzt gehe ich mit dem mixer hier in den
pudding und dann wird also 30 40
sekunden aufgelockert also einfach mixen
und dann kann man es auf jeden fall ganz
einfach unternehmen so gestaltet sich
das natürlich schwierig aber es wird ein
bisschen geschmeidiger die sahne wird
dann unter gehoben und dann ist die
creme fertig übrigens könnt ihr wenn ihr
möchtet noch einen schuss orangenblüten
wasser mit rein geben denn der polnische
patissier der quasi die tat tropez
ziehen erfunden hat der hat auch
orangenblüten was haben wir ein gegeben
alexandra wenn ich mich recht erinnere
ich hab's euch gerade gebogen ich hab
schon wieder vergessen aber ich habe mir
hintergrund einfach so interessant und
ich habe mich gewundert als verstand er
gibt orangenblüten was er mit reichlich
kingston aus der arabischen welt des
orientalischen welt aber ums
originalgetreu zu machen mache ich das
heute gibt es ein ganzes stückchen
gleich am ende noch mit rein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so die ruhezeit ist oben detail konnte
gut entspannen und ein wenig aufgehen
und wir machen jetzt so weiter hier auf
der arbeitsfläche ein bisschen mehl
diesmal und dann kommt der teig einmal
auf die arbeitsfläche ja der klebt jetzt
auch nicht mehr und einfach rauslassen
und wenn ihr eigentlich vorher gute
arbeit geleistet habt und ist schon rund
gerollt haben rund geformt habt dann
müsst ihr gar nicht mehr so viel machen
zieht eigentlich schon ganz gut aus ihr
hättet ihr quasi die möglichkeit das
noch mal zu einer kugel zu formen
[Musik]
den teig dann einfach auf ein backblech
stellen ich hab jetzt hier das gelochte
backblech einfach ein backpapier unten
drunter und im prinzip wenn ihr wirklich
bin mit der form zufrieden seid hättet
ihr es auch direkt aufs backblech kippen
können quasi und dann ganz leicht mit
dem finger nochmal flach andrücken ich
habe jetzt noch den tortenring relativ
locker drumherum getan also das ist
wirklich noch so ein millimeter platz
denn falls es dann im ofen irgendwie
noch mal es wird natürlich noch ein
bisschen größer im ofen aber falls es
noch mal die breite geht habt ihr keine
ovale form sondern eine runde da hilft
euch die torten bringen und ist dann
quasi wie so eine schutzwand und ihr
seht jetzt hier auch am tortenring dass
ich dem teig ungefähr 2 cm hoch
ausgebreitet habe höher brauche auch gar
nicht sein jetzt das ganze noch mit der
gelb wasser mischung bestreichen einfach
das eigelb mit ein bisschen wasser
verrühren und dann ganz wichtig und ganz
ganz typisch ist hagelt zucker da wird
jetzt auch noch drauf verteilt und dann
kommt unser prior steig in den backofen
[Musik]
unsere branche dürfte jetzt bei 180 grad
ober und unterhitze im backofen für 25
minuten backen
und ich jetzt natürlich ein bisschen
ausdampfen lassen ihr könnt es jetzt
entweder komplett abkühlen und dann
durch schneiden oder ihr lasst uns
wirklich in ruhe ausdampfen und können
das noch lauwarm durchschneiden und
anschließend komplett abkühlen geht es
ein bisschen schneller und es löst sich
hier eigentlich viel von alleine braucht
man nicht mal backform löse heute und
ich finde es sieht jetzt schon richtig
treffen wird eine richtig schöne farbe
und jetzt entweder mit einem langen
gewählten messer oder mit einer torte
säge hier sind auch wellen dran einmal
schön durch schreiben
[Musik]
so ich hab mir jetzt meine creme aus dem
kühlschrank geholt und ihr könnt
natürlich entscheiden ob er vielleicht
einen stern telefon dran macht oder eine
loch thüle schön ist halt nur wenn man
außen auch sieht dass da etwas fein
säuberlich gespritzt wurde ihnen ist es
egal da kommt der deckel drauf also
kommt jetzt hier auf mein abgekühlten
boden die creme einmal pünktchen weise
außen herum ihnen fühle ich da nur auf
und dann kommt der decke und ein
bisschen puderzucker
[Musik]
ich finde die ta tropez zielle richtig
schön ich bin das ist wieso man kennt ja
auch vom bäcker diese schönen streusel
taler mit richtig dick und fett
vanillepudding drin das hier ist so eine
art nur noch mal in der deluxe in der
deluxe variante und einfach in xxxl und
ich probiert natürlich auch mal für euch
ich weiß natürlich sehr sehr lecker
schmeckt wenn dort alleine der haben sie
ist heute im shop aber heute abend freut
er sich wenn er auch seit stück ab
bekommt
also sehr soft oben aber durch den hagel
zucker ein bisschen cross richtig schöne
kombi und der vanillepudding genial
orangenblüten wasseramt man nur ein
wenig ganz dominant ist jetzt hier
natürlich die vanille und an sich der
branche ist so oder ist einfach nur so
fluffig und einfach perfekte kombi aus
wirklich oben ein bisschen cross aber
geradezu angenehm weich cremig ihr habt
ihr alles dabei macht es unbedingt nach
ich denke der schmeckt frisch man am
besten wenn es am nächsten tag essen
wollt bitte komplett überdecken keine
luft ranlassen und dann im kühlschrank
aufbewahren und vor dem verzehr am
besten 30 minuten vor herausnehmen ja
ansonsten verabschiede ich mich an der
stelle ich möchte aber noch jemanden
grüßen und zwar andere denn durch sie
kam ich auf diesen kuchen und sie hat
mich darauf aufmerksam gemacht schon vor
jahren 19 habe ich ihn endlich mal
gebacken also wie gesagt macht unbedingt
nach und habe ganz viel spaß dabei lasst
es euch schmecken und hinterlasst main
kanal auf jeden fall ein kostenloses abo
wenn ihr das nicht schon längst getan
hat dann sehen wir uns auch beim
nächsten video
chat
produzierte gerade schon system gehabt
und jetzt muss ich wissen ich muss
leider hab ich muss jetzt noch ein test
machen das ja nicht gerade einfach ein
ganz schlechtes wetter und jetzt kommt
der wechsel die über das hinaus was ist
das eine doch jetzt weiß ich dass
aussieht da oben sowieso salzstöcke aber
so schöne seine stücke sind ich und es
passt richtig zu optiken oder sogar eine
bestimmte also man kann das stück gerne
kippen dann lässt es sich auf jeden fall
leichter essen
[Musik]
hat so ein bisschen so winzig charakter
haben ja auch ein bienenstich erinnert
ein bisschen an sträuße daran gewöhnt
wieder weil eine politik
wie findest du so die die schicht um die
ist schon ein bisschen so knackig und
dann kommt so ein beispiel ist ja ich
erreiche das ist nämlich der
steuerzahler das immer so fest aber
nicht zu fest und dann geht's weiter
genau dann hat man die fette war die
geschichte hat hat doch ein bisschen so
wie der herr trägt in diesem alles so
ein stadtteil von helen chaitman wächst
ja ja das ist es
adios amigos
[Musik]